no streetcar was running and it was flat
completely flat so I was able to walk
from the East End train station eight
Rivers
it Bridges to home with this big bag of
rice chitama was 22 years old living in
Hiroshima Japan in August 1945 when the
U.S dropped an atomic bomb over the city
but shatama was not there the day before
she had taken a train to a friend's
house a few Towns over to pick up a bag
of rice when she returned to the
Hiroshima train station the next day she
faced a land ravaged by war shitama did
not see a living Soul on the several
mile Trek to her family's home when she
arrived four miles from the epicenter of
the bomb the house was still standing
but the neighborhood was devastated
[Music]